part two of reading the letter that i
wrote to my future self when i was 17.
dear 21 year old hannah i hope you're
still catholic and closer to your faith
than ever i hope you've learned to love
the way that you look and who you are i
hope that you find a man who treats you
better than you think you deserve i hope
you're a national champion by now i hope
that you look back on high school and
smile because you didn't know there was
better things ahead i hope you found
something that you're passionate about
that you want to do for the rest of your
life i hope you're still friends with
bethany bucci brooke reynolds and emily
castleto
i hope that you are the best big sister
and little sister you can be and have
have found a best friend in your
siblings i hope you believe you're as
smart as you are i hope that you stop
putting yourself down and are more
confident in who you are i hope you
don't become a [ __ ] in college i hope
you stay true to what you believe and
who you are i hope you prove everyone
wrong sincerely 17 year old hannah